Was Obama's postpartum and agenda is
that he came into it,
he came into his presidency,
uh,
at a time when millions of Americans,
perhaps even tens of millions of
Americans,
don't consider a Democrat president
legitimate,
don't get sued of liberalism,
legitimate dunk.
Consider the idea of the state for my
new programs to help people legitimate.
Uh,
so he's in a situation,
a lot like a,
you know,
Abraham Lincoln face in 1860,
when you had millions of Americans who
didn't even consider what was going on
in Washington to have anything to do
with them.
So,
uh,
the big question for me was always was
this post partisan idea,
this idea that you could kind of bring
adversaries across the table and get
them to agree to each other and agree
with to get them to agree with each
other and uh,
achieve social progress.
Was that a deep seated belief of his or
was that in a certain sense,
a tactic?
Not as cynical tactic,
but a tactic?
And,
uh,
I would be very with him if it were a
way of thinking about politics,
if it were a tactic.
Because the job of a transformative
leader is not too huge the center,
but to define their own values as the
center as commonsense.
And,
uh,
if he,
you know,
I,
I believe in the agenda he's passed,
he's,
he's putting far,
for example,
universal healthcare,
you know,
for example,
uh,
you know,
cap and trade and green jobs as a way to
solve our energy problems while growing
the economy.
I think these are reasonable,
uh,
while liberal goals and,
if he presents them as reasonable and
the reaction to them as one could knew
they were going to be,
because there are these millions of
people who don't consider a liberal
president.
Legitimate was irrational extreme that
presented him an opportunity to say,
my program is rational,
but my opposition has chosen extremism,
has chosen unreasoned and be willing to
take the hit that there's always going
to be a minority of the country.
30%,
35%,
even 40% who disagrees with him
radically disagrees with him strongly.
But if he's still willing to pass his
program with debt,
60% margin,
the rest of the country will eventually
catch up.
The reaction.
Notice we'll understand as they did with
social security as they did with,
you know,
women getting the vote,
freeing the slaves,
you know,
a social security that actually these
things were in their interests.
They'll accept them as part of the
established order of American society.
And in fact,
20,
30,
40,
down years,
years down the road,
the Republicans and the Conservatives
will be campaigning to see if universal
health care,
just like they can't paint to save
social security.
But the problem is this doesn't really
work unless you make this kind of
tactical shift.
If people say that you're illegitimate
and,
uh,
your liberal agenda is extremist
socialist,
uh,
destroying the America that we all grew
up with.
You have to be willing to say this is
unreasonable.
This is extreme.
And if you aren't able to say this is
unreasonable and this is extreme,
then you're granting your opposition,
uh,
an undue influence.
You're basically,
uh,
negotiating with the under negotiate
bubble.
And,
uh,
as Abraham Lincoln said quite eloquently
in his 1860 speech at Cooper Union,
uh,
you can't win that way.
I've been saying for years that,
uh,
you know,
there are millions of Americans who
basically don't consider,
uh,
the liberal project legitimate.
They consider it the opposite of what
America means to them and,
uh,
that they derive their identity from
questioning the legitimacy and the
ability of the liberal government to,
to function peacefully.
So,
uh,
I think that for a couple months,
even more maybe six months,
uh,
Barack Obama's charisma and his,
his remarkable popularity,
uh,
kind of stunned some of these people
into silence.
I think people couldn't quite believe
what they're saying.
But if you,
if you,
if you look at it historically,
it's,
you know,
quite continuous with what happened when
Bill Clinton became president.
You know,
when you began to hear people,
you know,
a accusing him of,
uh,
you know,
murdering his aids.
You know,
when you began to have,
uh,
people,
saying that he was actually,
uh,
you know,
ancient for a,
the Soviet Union,
which he had visited when he was a
child,
or when he was a teenager,
when he was in college.
And you saw the same thing when Jimmy
Carter became president.
And,
uh,
you know,
um,
he was immediately considered a part of
this,
uh,
corrupt Democratic Party establishment.
Uh,
it happened every time a Democrat was
elected in,
it will happen.
Every time a Democrat is elected.
It's,
it's,
it's part of our patrimony as Americans.
And the challenge for a Barack Obama or
any democrat or any liberal is to
understand that this is just part of who
we are as Americans.
To acknowledge it,
to respect it,
and to transcend it.
And,
uh,
you know,
the lion can lay down with the lamb,
but it's not going to last for very
long.